.
Tschau.
- Tschüss.
Mach's gut! Du weisst ...
Alles wird gut.
Du weisst es.
- Ja, schon gut.
* Sentimentale Gitarrenklänge *
Es ist schon etwas ...
Vom Bodensee ans Mittelmeer:
Im sonnigen Spanien
wollen Corinne und Ralf Waldburger
ein Hundehotel bauen.
Auf nach Afrika:
Dianne und Marco Schommer
eröffnen in Ruanda ein Fitnesscenter.
Hoch hinaus:
Ein über 100-jähriger
Wasserturm an der Nordsee
ist Familie Caboussats neue Zukunft.
# Uf u dervo.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Lokaltermin
beim Wasserturm von Cuxhaven.
Hast du dein Handy dabei?
- Ja, komm wir gehen mal rauf.
Dann wollen wir uns
dort oben mal umsehen.
Seit einigen Monaten
ist die Familie Caboussat
Besitzerin des stillgelegten
Wasserturms von Cuxhaven.
Der denkmalgeschützte Turm ist das
Wahrzeichen der Stadt an der Nordsee.
Vor zwei Jahren hatten die Schweizer
den Turm im Internet entdeckt.
Und sie verliebten sich in die Idee,
dereinst im Wasserturm
zu wohnen und zu arbeiten.
Schon allein das Treppenhaus
ist super schön.- Ja.
Es ist wahnsinnig schön.
Das Treppenhaus -
das ist historisch bedingt -
müssen, dürfen,
können wir so belassen,
Es ist auch die Idee,
es im Originalzustand beizubehalten.
Unter dem Dach: das Herzstück.
Hier befindet sich der Wassertank.
Die Wände des Wassertanks
reichen 12 m bis dort hinauf.
Genau, 12 m.
- Von hier aus gemessen.
Gross wie ein Einfamilienhaus
ist der Tank.
Sein Fassungsvermögen:
knapp 1 Mio. l Wasser.
* Beschwingte Klavierklänge *
Alles Wasser wurde abgelassen.
Vielleicht liegen
ein paar Fliegen am Boden,
vielleicht noch
ein paar andere Dinge.
Ich weiss es nicht,
habe noch nicht nachgeschaut.
Einmal leuchtete ich
mit einer starken Taschenlampe
von oben hinunter,
aber ich sah einfach nur schwarz.
Das ist ziemlich speziell.
In diese riesige, schwarze Wanne
wollen die Caboussats
ein Café einbauen.
Alain und ich lieben es, alte Sachen
wieder auf Neu zu trimmen.
Und ...
Als wir dieses Objekt besichtigten,
waren wir uns einig,
es im Originalzustand zu belassen,
wollten ihm aber
neues Leben einhauchen.
Es wäre natürlich witzig,
wenn wir in diesen Tank
ein Café so einbauen könnten,
dass man die Wände sieht.
Das würde dem Café
ein spezielles Flair geben.
Ich erinnere mich noch,
als wir zum ersten Mal
daran vorbeigegangen sind.
Ich stupste Alain an
und sagte zu ihm:
"Wenn wir einmal sagen können:
'Das ist unser Turm.' Das wär was!"
Danach besuchten wir den Turm
noch einige Male,
da gehörte er noch nicht uns.
Und heute ist es so,
dass wir sagen können:
"He, das ist unser Turm."
Das Café im Wassertank
ist nur ein Teil ihres grossen Plans.
Die Gäste sollen von hier oben
ins Café hinunterschauen können.
Dafür braucht es ein hohes Geländer.
Das müssen wir einbauen.
Ja, das ist eben schon ...
Es ist eben schon ein schweres
Millionenprojekt, das ist so.
Dafür haben wir uns
ein gewisses Budget gesetzt.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen,
was wir damit alles umsetzen können,
was Sinn für die Zukunft macht,
wo wir Abstriche machen müssen.
Ein Café im Turm -
40 m hoch über der Stadt.
In einer Autowerkstätte
in der Schweiz
hat auch Ralf Waldburger
neue Zukunftspläne.
Kurz vor seinem 50. Geburtstag
will er sein Leben nochmals
komplett neu ausrichten - in Spanien.
Ich übergebe dir das gerne.
- Ja, das ist gut.
Seit neun Jahren
ist der gelernte Autolackierer
Chef des Ersatzteillagers.
Nun hat er
seinen sicheren Job gekündigt.
Heute ist sein letzter Arbeitstag.
Doch, das ist gut so.
Vielen Dank.
- Bitte schön!
Seit einem Jahr
ist Ralf mit Corinne verheiratet.
Die beiden haben sich
auf einer Datingplattform
im Internet kennengelernt.
In ihrem Zuhause
im thurgauischen Steinebrunn
bereitet Corinne Muffins
für Ralfs Abschiedsfest vor.
Es war Corinne, die Ralf zum
Abenteuer Auswanderung inspirierte.
Als Ralf das erste Mal
mit mir nach Spanien kam,
hat er sich eigentlich
sofort verliebt - in Spanien.
Und dann haben wir gesagt:
Wir versuchen es.
Wenn wir es nicht probieren,
wissen wir nicht, ob es klappt.
Dann suchten wir nach Ideen,
was wir in Spanien machen würden.
Daraufhin hörten wir uns
in Spanien etwas um,
was dort gefragt ist,
was wir unternehmen könnten.
Als der Vorschlag
mit den Hunden kam,
war ich sofort
Feuer und Flamme.
Das ist etwas,
was ich schon immer tun wollte.
Das ist eigentlich mein Baby,
die Sache mit den Hunden, ja.
Dann sind die Muffins bereit,
die lege ich jetzt ...
... aufs Blech.
Ein Hotel ausschliesslich für Hunde
wollen die Waldburgers bauen.
Für Hunde, deren Besitzer ohne
ihre Vierbeiner verreisen wollen.
Bist du zu Hause gewesen?
Ralfs Sohn Mischa hilft seinem Vater,
das Fest herzurichten.
Mischa verlor seine Mutter, Ralfs
erste Frau, vor drei Jahren an Krebs.
Umso enger
ist die Bindung zu seinem Vater.
Ja, für mich
fällt dadurch vieles weg.
Ich muss meine
erste eigene Wohnung suchen.
Ich werde allein sein. Mal schauen,
wie die Situation sein wird.
die Grosseltern, Patentante
und Kollegen sind noch da.
Mal schauen, wie es wird,
wenn Vater weit weg ist,
und ich ihn
nur ein paar Mal im Jahr sehe.
Aber ich bin optimistisch,
das kommt sicher gut.
Noch einmal Bratwürste
und Appenzeller Bier.
Ta-raa!
Das Dessertbuffet ist eröffnet.
Wenn jemand Lust auf Dessert hat?
Schau, Schweizer- und Spanienfahne.
Danke vielmals.
Hasta la vista heisst:
Auf Wiedersehen.
Ich weiss, so viel Spanisch
kann ich schon. Das ist super.
* Beschwingte
Ziehharmonika- und Klavierklänge *
Der Fischereihafen von Cuxhaven
ist einer
der grössten Häfen Deutschlands.
Und die Stadt am Meer
ein beliebtes Ferienziel.
Eine Schweizer Familie
will sich hier nun niederlassen.
Der denkmalgeschützte Wasserturm
ist ihr grosses Projekt.
Ein Architektenteam aus Hamburg
ist angereist.
Die Aussenfassade soll
nicht zu stark verändert werden.
Die Vorstellung der Dachgauben
wurde uns schon etwas klarer.
Das Treppenhaus beizubehalten,
war einfach Pflicht.
Eine aussergewöhnliche Aufgabe
auch für die Architekten.
Zum ersten Mal wagen sie sich
an ein solches Vorhaben.
Im unteren Teil des Turms
befanden sich einst
die Büros der städtischen Wasserwerke
und drei Wohnungen.
Die Räume sind natürlich genau so
hoch, wie ich es erwartet habe:
über 4 m.
Die ursprüngliche Idee war,
dass hier, wo wir stehen,
ein Gewerbe einziehen würde.
Sei das eine Boutique,
eine Weinhandlung,
etwas Spezielles wäre schön.
Und in den
darüber liegenden Stockwerken,
also im ersten und im zweiten Stock,
wollen wir ein Bed and Breakfast
mit je zwei Zimmern einrichten.
Und im dritten Stock wollen wir
eine Ferienwohnung einrichten,
für die wir schon
einen Namen gefunden haben:
das Berner Zimmer.
Und unterhalb des Kessels
geht es dann hinauf.
Dort oben richten wir
den Technikraum ein.
Die gesamte Technik
soll dort oben bleiben.
Dort oben wollen wir
auch das Café einrichten
und vielleicht, wenn es geht,
noch eine Wohnung.
Bevor Mirabelle und Alain
den Turm kauften,
liessen sie Gutachten erstellen.
Ursprünglich hatten wir
eine Architektin gefragt,
ob das Fundament noch gut ist.
Sollen wir diesen Turm kaufen?
Oder ist es eine Bauruine,
die komplett renoviert werden muss?
Es zeigte sich, dass Fundament
und Bausubstanz gut sind
und der Turm umgenutzt werden darf:
Die Schweizer schlugen zu.
Heute geht es noch nicht um Details,
sondern um
strukturelle bauliche Massnahmen.
Der Aufzug, der bisher
geplant war, hat die Schwierigkeit,
dass es keinen Vorraum gibt.
Genau die 6 m2?
- Genau.
Wir haben eine Idee entwickelt,
die ich Ihnen zeigen werde.
Wenn wir den Aufzug
in die Mitte setzen,
könnte man ihn in's Café führen.
Das ergäbe
eine andere Raumaufteilung.
Das ist auch ganz spannend.
Dann wäre der Aufzug
nicht mehr hier,
sondern in der Mitte.
Ja, hier, genau hier.
Im runden Flur, sozusagen.
Der Architekt
hat einen ungefähren Zeitplan.
Ganz grob,
ohne dass wir uns festlegen müssen.
Dieses Jahr wird geplant
und nächstes
Jahr beginnen wir mit dem Bau.
Wie lange das braucht,
müssen wir dann schauen.
Mit einem Jahr Bauzeit
muss man schon rechnen.
Sie müssen sich sicher sein:
Das wollen wir
und das Budget haben wir.
Wir haben schon einmal
ein Haus umgebaut.
Wir wissen,
dass nicht alles nach Plan läuft.
Das ist einfach so.
Aber wir sind sehr zuversichtlich,
dass das gut kommen wird.
Die Caboussats fühlen sich
bestärkt in ihrem Vorhaben.
In den nächsten Wochen will
die Familie ihrer alten Heimat,
dem Emmental, für immer Adieu sagen.
Im solothurnischen Bettlach.
Für Dianne Schommer sind gemeinsame
Essen mit der Familie wichtig.
Jetzt erst recht, denn schon bald
verlassen sie und ihr Ehemann
die Schweiz ― für immer.
Als Dianne in den 90er-Jahren aus
ihrer Heimat Ruanda flüchten musste,
war die Schweiz ihr Zufluchtsort.
Sie integrierte sich schnell.
Bei einem Treffen mit Freunden lernte
sie ihren späteren Mann Marco kennen.
Und eine Woche später
sind wir zusammen gewesen.
Das ist jetzt 22 Jahre her.
Und jetzt nehme ich ihn
mit nach Afrika.
Trotz der guten Jahre in der Schweiz,
Dianne zieht es
in die alte Heimat zurück.
Am Neuenburgersee in einer
internationalen Uhrmacherschule:
Hier arbeitet der Afrika-Auswanderer
Marco Schommer, Diannes Ehemann.
Can you come quick?
Heute beginnen die Schüler
ihre zweijährige Ausbildung.
(Englisch)
Seit dem Abschluss
seines Ingenieurstudiums
arbeitet Marco in der Uhrenindustrie.
Nun leitet er
die Schule interimistisch.
Seine vorherige,
langjährige Anstellung
verlor er
nach einer Umstrukturierung.
In dieser Situation
fand Marco immer mehr Gefallen
an den Auswanderungsträumen
seiner Frau.
Es war richtig,
dass ich 20, 22 Jahre
hier mit ihr gelebt habe.
Jetzt machen wir es
einmal umgekehrt,
dass ich bei ihr lebe,
dort, wo sie eigentlich herkommt.
Gut.
Seine Frau Dianne hat bereits
eine ausgereifte Geschäftsidee.
Und Marco will vor Ort
eine neue Aufgabe suchen.
Ja, wenn man auswandert,
ist das ein Risiko.
Dann verlässt man
das gewohnte Leben.
Man lässt sich
auf eine neue Sache ein.
Das ist eben ein wenig ...
Ja, das kann klappen -
oder eben nicht, voilà.
Aber ich sage mir immer:
Ich habe gewisse Talente, die
anderswo auch jemand brauchen kann.
Da habe ich keine grosse Angst.
Zum Abendessen hat Marco Schommer
seinen Sohn Dylan abgeholt.
Dylan ist gelernter Bauzeichner.
Wie war dein erster Arbeitstag?
- Nicht schlecht.
Hallo.
(Dianne) Hallo.
Hi Dylan.
- Hi Mom.
Der 22-Jährige lebt in Bern.
Er wird in der Schweiz bleiben.
Kannst du mir die Zwiebeln reichen?
- Wo?
Ich habe es
schon eine Weile gewusst.
Ich weiss es eigentlich
seit letztem Jahr.
Aber es ist trotzdem
noch nicht ganz echt für mich.
Es wird erst dann wirklich wahr,
wenn sie dann
tatsächlich abgereist sind.
Aber bis dann versuche ich,
möglichst oft hier zu sein.
Vorher war es: "Juhu, ich gehe!"
Und jetzt wird es
langsam schmerzhaft,
weil ich mich hier
wirklich zu Hause gefühlt habe.
Nach 27, 28 Jahren -
das ist eine lange Zeit.
Ich bin länger hier,
als ich in Afrika war.
Es beginnt zu schmerzen.
Ja.
Ich bin hier angekommen.
* Sentimentale Gitarrenklänge *
Trotz der vielen Jahre
in der Schweiz ...
So, gehen wir essen.
Mhm.
Ruandische Traditionen hat Dianne
über all die Jahre beibehalten.
Die Kleider,
die ich beim Kochen getragen habe,
wechsle ich
für das Essen am Esstisch.
Ich ziehe mir etwas Frisches an.
Schmeckt's?
- Ist lecker, ja.- Danke.
Zum Wohl, Frau Schommer.
Und was wirst du vermissen?
- Oh, alles.
Was alles?
Die ganze Schweiz.
Fondue vielleicht?
Kollegen und Freunde
werden uns ganz bestimmt fehlen.
(Dylan) Mich z.B.
- Ja, natürlich.
Das hat etwas lange gedauert.
Oh!
* Entspannte Reggae-Klänge *
Wir müssen erst
das Gestell aufstellen und dann ...
In Romanshorn bezieht Mischa
Waldburger seine erste Wohnung.
Jetzt, wenn der Vater auswandert,
muss der 20-Jährige
auf eigenen Beinen stehen.
Du musst vorausgehen,
du musst voraus.
Es ist sicher eine Herausforderung.
Ich wusste nicht,
dass mein Vater Hunde mag.
Wir hatten nie einen Hund.
Darum: mal schauen.
Das wird bestimmt spannend.
Doch das Bauen und Betreiben
eines Hotels für Hunde
ist für Ralf eine beglückende
neue Lebensperspektive.
So können wir eigentlich ihren Traum
erfüllen, aber auch meinen Traum.
Ich gärtnere gerne und
liebe es auch, herum zu werkeln.
Wir stehen nicht mehr unter
Zeitdruck, das ist mir wichtig.
Nicht, dass man aufstehen und
sein Arbeitspensum erledigen muss,
sondern noch einen zweiten Kaffee
trinken kann
und erst dann
mit der Arbeit beginnt.
Erst planten wir
eine Shisha-Bar unten am Strand
oder irgend so etwas in der Art.
Aber sowas
macht heutzutage ja jeder.
Und dann beauftragten wir unsere
Freunde, die in Spanien leben,
wie z.B. eine
ehemalige Schulkollegin von mir,
die Eltern von Corinne
und ein weiteres Paar,
sie sollen sich herum hören,
welche Bedürfnisse
in dieser Gegend vorhanden sind.
Sie gaben uns den Tipp,
dass so etwas
wie ein Hundehotel fehlt.
Die Geschäftsidee Hundehotel
war geboren.
In Bad Ragaz im Sarganserland geht
Corinne das Vorhaben tatkräftig an.
Ja, jetzt ...
In einem Hundehotel lernt
die 47-Jährige alles über Hunde.
Ja, das magst du, gell.
Hier kann ich lernen,
wie sie es so machen.
So, wie es hier organisiert ist,
finde ich perfekt.
Das will ich für uns
jedenfalls auch beibehalten.
Wir wollen die Zimmer
mit einzelnen Boxen ausstatten
und jedes Zimmer zu einem
verschiedenen Thema gestalten,
so wie die Zimmer in einem Hotel,
das war eigentlich unsere Idee.
Wenn der Hund nach Hause geht,
machen wir die Box komplett frisch,
und alles kommt in die Wäsche.
Gut.
Mit Tieren zu arbeiten,
war schon immer Corinnes Traum.
Damals, bei der Berufswahl,
siegte jedoch die Vernunft.
Sie absolvierte
eine kaufmännische Ausbildung.
Mein Bürojob war ganz okay,
es war ein Job,
aber es war kein Job für das Herz.
Wenn man mit Hunden zusammenarbeiten
kann, ist das für's Herz.
Eine Herzensaufgabe
bei Regen und bei Sonnenschein.
Ich will nach Spanien.
Schau dir dieses Wetter an!
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
In Bettlach
sind Männer mit Muskeln gefragt.
(Französisch)
Heute beladen sie
den Container für Ruanda.
Im Keller muss sich Dianne Schommer
von Erinnerungsstücken trennen.
So viele Sachen.
Was kommt mit nach Afrika?
Was bleibt hier und wird entsorgt?
Das hat Dylan
in der Schule gebastelt.
Es tut mir sehr leid, dass ich
all das nicht mitnehmen kann.
Doch in Ruanda
wartet eine vielversprechende Zukunft
auf das Ehepaar.
Wir haben den Plan, in Ruanda
etwas mit Sport zu unternehmen.
In Kigali, der Hauptstadt von Ruanda,
sieht die 49-Jährige eine Chance,
die sie in der Schweiz
wohl nie hätte.
Die Zumba-Instruktorin will
ein eigenes Fitnesscenter eröffnen.
Ich denke, es ist jetzt die Zeit
gekommen, etwas zu verwirklichen.
Je älter wir werden,
desto schwieriger wird es.
Ich denke,
der Zeitpunkt ist jetzt ideal,
weil unser Sohn
mittlerweile erwachsen ist.
Jetzt können wir uns
diese Freiheit nehmen.
* Afrikanische Trommelklänge *
Aber für Marco ist es natürlich ...
nicht einfach.
Ich schätze es sehr,
dass er mitkommt.
* Sie sprechen französisch. *
Marco unterstützt seine Dianne,
wo immer er kann.
Heute ist er für
das Verladen ihrer Zukunft zuständig.
Dazu braucht es viel Muskelkraft
von Kollegen - und einen Hubstapler.
Ja, ohne ihn
würde hier nichts laufen.
21 neue Trampoline aus Tschechien
und 18 gebrauchte Fitnessgeräte,
ein Geschenk
von Diannes ehemaligem Arbeitgeber.
Die Ruander
sind sehr sportorientiert.
Es gibt noch nicht sehr viele,
qualitativ gute Fitnessstudios.
So gesehen sind diese Geräte
wohl die modernsten in Ruanda,
obwohl sie eigentlich
schon veraltet sind.
Dieses hier?
Das ist ein Muscle-up-Gerät.
Ihr Wohnhaus in Langnau im Emmental
haben die Caboussats verkauft.
Tagelang haben sie ausgemistet.
Ein voller Laster,
das ist die ganze Habe,
die sie mit ins neue Leben
an die Nordsee nehmen.
Hilfst du mir schnell,
das dort rüber zu stellen?
Ist das besser,
wenn wir erst die Kisten raustragen?
Oder zuerst die Möbel?
Oha! Yannis -
Achtung, Schwertransport.
Mirabelle Caboussat
hat den aufwendigen Umzug
sorgfältig vorbereitet.
Nun geht es plötzlich schnell -
viel zu schnell.
Die Zügelmänner
kamen rund 2 Std. zu früh angefahren.
Ja, das setzt uns unter Druck,
eindeutig.
Da haben wir den ganzen Tag
so viel eingepackt, dachten ...
Wir haben nonstop
eingepackt und eingepackt.
Und plötzlich taucht
noch dies und jenes auf.
All das kleine Zeug, das uns
völlig aus dem Konzept bringt.
Es geht Schlag auf Schlag.
Wenn es in der Kiste
nicht scheppert und knallt,
wissen wir,
dass nichts kaputtgehen wird.
Achtung, Schatz!
Die Bilder nicht hierhin,
sonst kommen sie nicht vorbei.
Achtung! Oben!
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Die Zügelmänner wollen
so schnell wie möglich losfahren.
Schatz, willst du auch was trinken?
Ah, das war nicht mein Schatz.
Sicher auch attraktiv,
aber nicht meiner.
Alles auf dieser Seite
nicht einladen.
Alles darf nicht mit,
denn Alain ist Messeleiter
und sein Arbeitgeber
braucht ihn noch für einen Monat.
In dieser Zeit übernachtet er
im alten, fast leeren Zuhause.
Nein, das gehört uns.
Schatz?
- Ja.
Schatz, wir müssen das erledigen.
Wir müssen wirklich vorwärtsmachen,
die wollen losfahren.
Ich weiss, aber ich muss
noch die Sandwiches holen.
Nein, schicke Nicolas.
Du musst das hier managen,
sagen, was hier passiert.
Ja, ist gut.
Gut,
Sie sind noch nicht losgefahren.
Die Koffer nicht mitnehmen.
Das klappt, die Koffer bleiben hier.
Nur Alains Matratze verschwindet
trotz erhöhter Aufmerksamkeit
im Bauch des Lasters.
Das werden harte Nächte
für den 47-Jährigen.
Jetzt kann ich
nicht mehr hier schlafen.
Das wird zu einer Herausforderung.
Ich habe nicht einmal
einen Schlafsack,
die sind zuhinterst im Lastwagen.
Aber dein Duvet
habe ich in die Ecke gelegt.
Das ist hoffentlich noch dort.
Das Duvet schon, trotzdem wird es
hart, am Boden zu schlafen.
Die Matten und auch
die Polstergruppe sind weg.
Das Leben ist hart.
Nimmst du diese Kiste mit?
- Schlaf doch auf dem Teppich.
Das glaube ich ja nicht.
Die fackeln nicht lange: Was herum-
liegt, packen sie ein, und ist weg.
Yannis wird in der neuen Heimat
die obligatorische Schulzeit beenden.
Sein älterer Bruder Nicolas
beginnt schon bald
die Cuxhavener Berufsbildungsschule.
Ja, ich konnte mich
darauf einstellen,
denn ich weiss ja schon länger,
dass wir wegziehen.
Deshalb bin ich jetzt
nicht total gestresst oder genervt.
Ich bin nicht traurig,
dass wir gehen.
Ich konnte mich
auf das Neue vorbereiten.
Ich bin geschafft.
Ich bin froh,
dass alles verladen ist.
* Entspannte Ziehharmonikaklänge *
Noch ein letztes Mal
gemeinsam vor dem Haus sitzen.
Über zehn Jahre war es ihr Daheim,
noch scheint alles unwirklich.
Also ich freue mich sehr auf
das Neue, nicht bloss auf Cuxhaven,
sondern darauf,
eine neue Erfahrung zu machen.
Klar, ist das
ein sehr spezieller Moment.
Für mich ist es
noch nicht so unmittelbar,
ich bin noch einen Monat hier.
Deshalb ist das Gefühl des Abschieds
noch wenig präsent.
Das ist so.
Also, los.
* Entspannte Ziehharmonikaklänge *
Hinaus in die Emmentaler Natur.
Ein letztes Mal bei der
Lieblingsfeuerstelle bräteln.
Durchatmen - Innehalten.
Ihr Leben wird sich
grundlegend verändern.
Die Schweiz ist bald Vergangenheit.
Mir reicht es, den Abschied
nur so nebenbei zu erwähnen.
Ich sage: "Tschüss",
dann ist eigentlich gut für mich.
Angst habe ich nicht.
Aber Respekt habe ich.
Respekt vor dem Unbekannten,
das auf einen zukommen kann.
Wir müssen loslassen können.
Aber ich denke,
das können wir schon.
Oder nicht?
- Ja, es geht.
Wovor hast du Angst?
Angst nicht,
aber meine Freunde loszulassen ...
Ich werde bestimmt noch
mit ihnen snappen oder chatten.
Das ist auch verständlich.
So, Schnuckiputz.
Der Tisch ist gedeckt:
ein kulinarischer Mix
aus afrikanischen
und schweizerischen Spezialitäten.
Dianne und Marco Schommer
nehmen heute Abschied.
Zu diesem einmaligen Anlass
liess Dianne in Ruanda
Kleider für die ganze Familie nähen.
Marco hat
ein Video zusammengeschnitten.
Auszüge von Zumba-Stunden,
die Dianne in Kigali
schon probeweise gegeben hatte.
Gut.
Schnucki, ich habe
eine kleine Überraschung für dich.
Oh Gott, nein, bitte nicht.
- Warte jetzt.
Schau dir das an.
- Zumba.
Ja, let's dance.
Cool, nicht?
- Super hast du das gemacht.
Du bist gut.
* Schmatz von Kuss *
Zumba in Ruanda.
Voilà, ça c'est très bien.
* Energetische Tanzmusik: "Shut Up
and Dance" von Walk the Moon *
# Shut up and dance,
dance, dance, dance.
Also ich denke,
das wird schon gut kommen.
Weil in Ruanda im Moment
Sport wirklich angesagt ist.
Es muss.
Ich will nichts anderes hören.
* Afrikanische Gitarrenklänge *
Über 60 Gäste
feiern mit den Schommers Abschied.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl.
In all den Jahren in der Schweiz
hat Dianne viele Freunde gefunden.
Haben alle einen Platz gefunden?
Worum geht es?
* Lachen *
Ich sitze um 5.30 Uhr im Zug,
fahre nach Neuenburg,
bereite mich auf den Tag vor,
Sitzung an Sitzung
reiht sich aneinander.
Dann ein kurzes Telefongespräch
mit meinem Schnuckeli,
bevor es weitergeht.
Um 20 oder 21 Uhr abends
komme ich wieder nach Hause.
Mein Schnuckeli
befindet sich am Abend im Lifestyle.
Schnuckeli bin ich.
* Lachen *
Dort gibt sie Zumba-Unterricht.
Kurz treffen wir noch Dylan,
und so geht es tagein, tagaus.
Eines Tages sagt Dianne zu mir:
"Du, ich will nach Ruanda."
"Ich bin hier in der Schweiz
zu wenig ausgelastet."
"In unserem Land Ruanda
gibt es noch so viel zu tun."
"In Sachen Sport
könnte ich etwas beitragen."
Liebe Familie, liebe Freunde,
jetzt kommt der schwierigste Moment,
der emotionalste:
das Abschiednehmen von euch allen.
V.a. von Dylan,
Flora, Familie Stark ...
der Familie Meili ...
und natürlich von Marianne,
der Schweizer Mutter von Schnuckeli.
Merci beaucoup.
Adieu sagen - der wohl schwierigste
Moment einer Auswanderung.
Vielleicht der Moment, in dem man
für einen kurzen Augenblick
alles nochmals
rückgängig machen möchte.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Katze Caruso war sein Leben lang
in der Schweiz
und jetzt wandert er
nach Spanien aus.
Mir tut er leid, weil er nicht
weiss, was mit ihm passiert.
Aber da müssen wir heute alle durch,
alle miteinander, das Büsi und wir.
Macht's gut!
Freunde und natürlich Ralfs Eltern,
Ernst und Edith, sind da.
Bis später, sage ich.
- Ja, ja.
Ich bin auch etwas traurig,
dass wir alle unsere Lieben
hier zurücklassen müssen.
Aber wir freuen uns,
wenn alle auf Besuch kommen,
auch wenn meine Schwiegereltern
uns besuchen
und wir ihnen alles zeigen können.
Tschau.
- Tschüss.
Mach's gut. Du weisst ...
- Ja.
Viel Erfolg.- Danke.
- Alles wird gut.- Sicher.
Wir hören uns.
Tschüss.
Macht's gut.
- Einen guten Start.
Wir sehen uns.
- Klar, super, sicher.
Du weisst es.
- Ja, schon gut.
Also, tschüss.
Der Abschied vom Junior war ...
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Es ist schon etwas ...
2 Std. später in Valencia.
Ich hätte die kurzen Hosen
anziehen können.
Ja, ja.
Trotz November: Die spanische Costa
Blanca kennt kaum neblige Tage.
Aber es ist nicht nur das Wetter,
auf das sich die Auswanderer freuen.
Corinnes Eltern
leben schon seit Jahren hier.
Das ist komisch.
Über 15 Jahre schon
leben meine Eltern in Spanien.
Jetzt ist komisch, dass ich sie
wieder öfter sehen werde.
Das hätten wir auch nie gedacht,
oder ich wenigstens.
Dass ich einen an Land ziehe,
der auswandern will!
Die Fahrt geht von der Küste weg
ins Landesinnere nach Benissa,
zu ihrem Grundstück.
Schau dir das an! Unser Logo!
Unser loco loco!
Das Anwesen mit zwei Häusern
haben die beiden
vor wenigen Monaten gekauft.
Wir haben es geschafft.
Corinnes Eltern, die Amherds,
sind zur Begrüssung gekommen.
Salü, hallo.
- Willkommen.
Hallo.
- Hallo Ralph.
Willkommen, bienvenido.
Hola, hola.
Oh! Papa, der Hund!
Flinti, das ist unser Essen.
Im Moment ist es einfach nur:
geniessen.
Heute Morgen
fuhren wir bei 6 °C los.
Und jetzt stehe ich da und weiss:
Ich bin für immer da.
Und es ist ruhig.
Zu Hause hörte man immer
den Lärm der Strasse.
Das ist einfach Hammer,
einfach nur Hammer.
Waldburgers spanisches Paradies
ist über 6'000 m2 gross,
bietet also genügend Raum, um ein
gepflegtes Hotel für Hunde zu bauen.
* Blöken *
Ländlich und ruhig gelegen
ist es nur 10 km vom Meer entfernt.
So, jetzt kannst du gleich raus.
Ja, gehen wir los.
Wir kommen gleich,
erst will ich Caruso raus lassen.
Schätzli, ist überall geschlossen?
Ja, ich habe alles abgeschlossen.
Also, dann lassen wir dich raus.
Hast du das Katzenfutter
im Rucksack?
Das ist zwar schon
Mischas Katze gewesen, früher,
aber mittlerweile
ist es eigentlich meine Katze.
Auch wenn wir
ein Hundehotel aufziehen,
und eine Katze etwas Konträres ist,
gehört er trotzdem
einfach zu unserer Familie.
* Korkenknall *
Eure Ankunft wird jetzt gefeiert.
Jetzt hast du
deine kurze Hose gefunden, sehr gut.
Vielen Dank für alles.
Herzlich willkommen.
- Gracias.
Ralph, herzlich willkommen,
bienvenidos.
Corazon.
Anfänglich leben die beiden Schweizer
im Poolhaus.
Schau dir das an.
Das grosse Wohnhaus
mit der Dachterrasse
wollen sie noch renovieren.
Hoppla!
In der nächsten Folge:
Grossreinemachen in Spanien.
Hm, da entdeckt man Sachen.
Eine Peeling-Maschine?
- Das ist für Fingernägel.- Super.
Kaum in Cuxhaven gibt es bei
den Caboussats erste Verzögerungen.
Die Baupläne für den Wasserturm
müssen geändert werden.
Die grösste Überraschung
ist der Aufzug,
der zwar geplant war,
aber nicht in dieser Grösse.
Und in Ruanda will Dianne Schommer
ihr Projekt starten.
Findet sie passende Räumlichkeiten
für ihr Fitnessstudio?
Das ist mega schön.
Wenn der Preis stimmt ...
# U si stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für es neus Dahei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Roger Schmid - 2020